Hi everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google today.
It is my absolute pleasure to welcome Duncan Jones,
Paula Patton and Toby Kebbell for Warcraft.
[inaudible].
Thank you.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
Thank you for happiness.
So just in case anybody isn't aware,
could you explain to us what Warcraft is?
Yes.
Many years ago,
actually 20 years ago,
a real time strategy game came out called Warcraft.
Um,
that was fantastic and I was a big fan of it.
I'm from blizzard 10 years ago,
a game called world of Warcraft came out,
which is the one that most people know about,
which is this massively multiplayer online role playing game,
um,
which supposedly over the 20 years of its existence,
Warcraft,
that is um,
100 million people have played so very well known computer game
and Paula and Toby,
how did you get introduced to the world of this Warcraft?
For me it was,
uh,
the script.
I did not know about it.
I know I was one of,
I was the one out and Duncan was the one who brought me into the world and to
the universe of Warcraft.
I love the script.
I am.
That's why I want it to be in the movie.
And then I met with Duncan and he showed me he's incredible visuals and the art
in the world.
He wanted to create his interpretation of that.
And I was blown away.
And then we also talked about character and you know,
we had kind of a scrape meeting and in the moment you said I'd like you to do
it.
And I said I would.
And then there were lawyers,
but in the moment,
and then there were lawyers.
That's always,
it always ends up.
Yeah,
you can't trust it in the moment.
But I,
but I,
but we said yes.
And then,
I mean Paula has places,
character,
corona who's really kind of the,
the,
the central Kay central character in the film.
And that we have these two sort of competing civilizations or can human and
Paula's character Garona is kind of the one who's stuck in the middle.
And so in some senses,
what the audience sees is through Garona his eyes
has that made her so interesting to play.
And then,
and then I got in my car and I went,
wait a minute.
I mean I've got to be half work,
half human and green.
I,
what have I done?
I don't know if I should have said yes,
the bed.
But then it began the most amazing adventure.
It was really incredible.
Then you ended up looking like this.
Yes.
So that was not so bad.
I,
I'll take it that big head.
Small Body.
Yeah,
the dirt and one week not out yet.
I'm sorry.
It's not that bad from the back.
It looks like me though.
I was a steward 10 it's not,
um,
I got involved because I'm speaking too loud.
Is that loud?
I'll hold it here.
Uh,
I got involved because of motion capture.
I just finished planet of the apes playing Cobra and I had found out through
sitting with legendary that they were going to do a picture using the same thing
and ask you,
you must be tired of it.
I said,
no,
it's an incredible craft or something.
I would love to learn more of WHO's directing this at Duncan Jones.
I was like,
no way is that really real?
And they were like,
yeah,
I was like,
you know,
cause sometimes you could go to do a job and they're like,
Duncan Jones,
you turn up and it's not,
it's my go back.
It's a lot of lying in these businesses is a lot of fibbing goes on.
Duncan Jones,
Michael Duncan Jones base.
Uh,
so I was very lucky and it's a phenomenal cast.
And so yeah,
I also got,
I,
I'm a console player who's,
I have three older.
That's too,
I have three older brothers,
uh,
who were all PC gamers and I'm very spit upon us as a console gamer.
You know,
it's like,
you know,
you don't do what I know the evil I possessed in the world.
So,
um,
I was very excited,
however,
to be involved and especially with the return.
It was a,
it was a great role and as you said,
it was the pre world.
It was that world before that we were telling the,
the beloved worldwide,
Toby,
you may,
you may be thought of thinking that you were involved because of the Mocap,
but truly,
um,
I was excited to work with you in particular because of the Black Mirror episode
that you did,
which I thought was absolutely fantastic and that blew my mind.
Yeah.
Love it.
So I'd imagine there's a great deal of sort of responsibility to the existing
players,
but there's also the urge to bring people who aren't necessarily as familiar or
maybe like heard of Warcraft before.
Um,
did you find that motivating or maybe a little intimidating?
I kind of felt a responsibility to,
I mean,
I wanted to do the movie and,
and God,
how many times in your life do you have the opportunity to make a film on this
skill scale?
You know,
creating a world on this scale.
Um,
but I felt a responsibility as a fan of the game and as someone who really
wanted to see a movie,
not only based in the Warcraft universe but just see gay,
I see a film based on a game that didn't suck.
I don't want to disrespect
all the people who've made movie based on games.
It's an incredibly hard thing to make a movie.
Yeah.
And actually finishes,
you know,
deserves respect just for getting it made.
But,
um,
I felt like the emphasis of,
of of film has to be about telling a story that the audience wants to watch as
opposed to trying to,
in some way,
viscerally recreating the experience of playing a computer game.
That's not what a movie based on a video game needs to be.
There needs to be a movie that you actually enjoy watching and characters you
care about.
And,
and knowing,
you know,
understanding that the setting of the film and understanding where you're trying
to get to by the end of it.
So are you saying you are not a fan of the Super Mario brothers movie that is
not an excellent video game adaptation?
Rob Kazinsky
constantly dissing that movie.
And I think that that's a little unfair.
Um,
I think,
I think one of the great things about this game in particular is that both sides
of heroes,
you know,
it's not a black and white,
like these are the bad guys and these are the good guys.
Um,
how,
how do you sort of adapt that to cinema?
Cause I'm sure fans of the game and,
and film fans are going to be torn.
I hope
they all,
I mean,
I think,
I think what,
what Toby and Paula Do,
who,
you know,
Toby's plays an old character.
Paula plays a character who's kind of in the middle of the two worlds.
Um,
you know,
I wanted to,
I thought if we're going to make this movie,
one of the things that fantasy films tend to do is they're trope is that the
humans,
the hobbits,
the cute ones,
those are the good guys.
Everything ugly is a bad guy.
Not that you're ugly.
Yeah.
Okay.
But the,
the idea was,
okay,
let's,
let's make a war movie and let's,
let's show the conflict from both sides and let's get the audience to care about
the characters on both sides and see the heroes on both sides and understand
that there's conflict arises,
not because there's good and bad necessarily,
but because there's a situation that doesn't seem to have a,
uh,
an easy solution.
And that's why,
and that's why the conflict happens.
The orks have lost their home world.
They have nowhere else they could go.
They've invaded this world that's rich and fertile and it has lots of space,
but there happens to be a civilization which already exists there.
And that's the humans and the,
and the other races which are based on as Roth.
And Paula,
I would say your character,
even more so than Toby's is caught in between the two sides.
Were there any things that you drew on from,
you know,
obviously we don't live in a fantasy world,
so method acting might be a little tougher,
but were there any things that you,
you really felt like you connected with in this?
Absolutely.
Um,
I think that's what made her a character I wanted to play because I found her to
be so complex and also evolve so much,
which is rare for character to do in a movie.
But I have to say,
I didn't know,
um,
how well and how believable it would be for us to imagine that you could watch a
movie and there would not be a good bud,
good boy,
a good guy or bad guy or the right being or the wrong being.
And Duncan,
I don't know what,
to me it's like very unique.
Don't you think,
Toby?
I can't remember a movie I've seen that pull that up and it really does work it.
And that's what makes this film so different is that if you are,
heart is not pulled by the oryx.
And honestly by Toby's incredible performance that mean Durotan and his
relationship with his family,
eh Ha,
moves you and you can't help but be moved and then there's of course you up help
yourself cause you're human and you like humans,
right?
I mean,
most of us,
I don't like all of them.
Yeah.
We're basically human.
I said,
so then you're going to find it.
But I think I just need to say that that's really special.
And so that for me,
I think I also play the part that we all feel,
which is that none of us sometimes,
well,
I was a nun.
A lot of us don't feel like Youi belong,
you know,
in this world.
I know.
I don't,
I mean,
I think that would,
that was certainly a key to your character.
Just a sense of belonging and,
and who,
who,
who deserves,
who's earned your loyalty.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I think that that's,
I,
I have,
um,
I had been born into a world of suffering and pain as this labor gold on,
and then I find myself in the human world and I'm,
and I'm embraced by them,
but I'm not sure how much are and,
and how real it is.
And,
um,
and you'll have spoiled.
I know exactly.
I was trying,
but as he as be Paula,
yes,
I'm the light has had its challenges and his blessings and um,
you draw on those challenges and to play a character like this,
speaking of sort of the humanizing of orcs,
there's one scene,
I hope we can talk about it,
but it's the very beginning.
And Toby,
your performance is just,
it's so human and it's,
it's interesting to see these massive hulking orcs with really human emotions
and like sensitivity.
What was,
what was that day like for you?
Uh,
like every day it was a,
I mean,
but in a good way in the sense that every day on set was a,
it was a very nurturing process of being,
you know,
the very lovey thing to say.
But it was a very loving process.
You know,
it was a big group of us as all cause we were all very happy in a,
in a family and a team.
And then even our Hoffling,
we,
it's like having a half sister.
She real system,
right?
I embrace and uh,
I didn't get to embrace it.
Yeah.
Isn't that a bad joke?
So,
so it's a process of,
I think everyone's a little tired of seeing the good guy,
bad guy thing.
I mean,
even with everything,
I try and do those,
you know,
everyone good can be terrible cause the behaviors,
the terrible thing,
not the person,
you know.
So,
uh,
we were more looking at what the behaviors were of these characters.
And I was lucky I got to play with a wonderful actress.
She played my wife and I was a father,
so it was a very easy,
a lot of my friends and older brothers are having children.
So it was it.
Yeah,
it's fun when you get to work on a scene like that.
My wife is,
is quite pregnant and we're going to have our first kip next month.
But in the scene that I think you're talking about Durotan play by Toby and
Draka,
his wife played by Anna Galvin,
who's fantastic.
She's very pregnant at the time and,
and uh,
she wants to go with t with a Durotan on this,
in the salt.
This,
um,
uh,
basically excursion into this new world.
And he says,
can you,
can you hide your fat belly?
And she says,
only if you can hide your fat head.
Now these are the kinds of things that I as a husband would love to say to my
wife but never would.
So as a director,
I get to write these things and say them in the film,
then she knows with love that,
that it's meant for her.
The true fantasy film.
I'd love to talk about the visuals of the orcs because that scene in particular
really sold it for me because I feel like you guys kept very true to the maybe
more art style of the game,
but you had to sort of humanize them because the game is a little more cartoony.
Um,
just as a byproduct.
I'm sure it's like computer rendering limitations,
but this is a weird thing to notice.
I was like,
they have chest hair,
like gave like realistic test hair,
but it's such a human thing.
Um,
and,
and I know Ilm worked on the film and they are just real life wizards
did some amazing stuff.
They built these,
uh,
these,
these simulations down to the way muscles jiggle.
So that,
I mean,
did they did huge amounts of work specially on facial capture and I'm Toby could
speak to that having been through different versions of that process,
but,
but just the amount of detail they got into what,
you know,
whether it's the,
like you say how,
how the hair works on the body,
um,
how the hair works on the head.
Obviously the muscle jiggle and fat juggle.
There was multiple layers of,
of simulation that they were doing,
um,
for every,
every movement of every org.
Yeah.
I mean they work tirelessly and basically all we are at dots.
At the end of the day,
our image disappears in these dots motor,
that incredible character that they've drawn,
they've created.
So we're the sort of spirit personality element of their incredible hard work.
But yeah,
they work tirelessly.
Ilm,
does that change your approach at all just because you are manifesting this sort
of entirely different physical character?
Or is it just the same way you would approach a role in your face?
It was going to be directly translated.
The way you're trying to translate your emotions,
you will approaches acted the same,
but you have to lose a lot of your pride.
You walk around in gray pajamas,
well everyone else is in Kulana with great songs and great facial hair.
You clean shaven in a,
in a special needs hat.
It's uh,
it's,
you know,
you lose your pride,
but that's important,
you know,
so that's the only element of the changes.
And Paula,
you,
I guess it was an advantage or disadvantage,
but your character has to be as physical as some of the ORCS,
but you didn't have the advantage of with CG,
you know,
being able to like have some extra muscle.
So what was the training process like for this?
Like I assume it was a very physical role.
It was,
it was very,
uh,
it was daunting.
It was challenging.
Um,
but I,
but I raised it.
It was something that I ended up loving.
Um,
yes,
I first they wanted me to aesthetically look like I could potentially be an org.
And,
uh,
so that meant a lot of protein in my diet and a lot of workouts.
So that was,
what was it,
six days a week,
two and a half hours a day,
which was [inaudible] at the beginning I thought I was going to throw up,
I didn't know how I was going to do it,
but he just kept on.
And then we added a sore training and knives and,
and,
and then we started to happen is the fear of how am I going to play half work,
half human.
And this warrior started to dwindle a bit because this physical accomplishment I
had to make,
you know,
for the film,
we started making me feel like I could be a warrior a bit.
Do you know,
not that I could do everything that go wrong.
It does,
but just the idea that you could potentially do it was an empowering.
And then I also learned how to ride a horse,
which I had never really done before.
And,
um,
so by the time I got to set,
I'm scared to death still.
Like,
I remember the day I had my trailer was like,
Oh my God,
I don't,
and um,
um,
but
I will,
I had given that much work over.
I was like,
someone's going to see this body.
I'm getting naked somewhere.
Okay.
That's what's going to happen.
Bad role.
I might be a bad performance,
but I'm getting naked.
I'm sorry.
It's one of the guys.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's true.
And um,
but then it was also the last bit though would be they gave me tests and these
contacts that really obscured by vision and with all of the things that I
learned and everything that Duncan,
I talked about the inner work and the character.
And then I felt like I could go out and play or,
but there,
but so it,
people were like,
you have to spend all those hours in makeup.
It isn't fair.
It wouldn't you rather be in a pajama.
And I would say,
no,
not for me because I love costumes.
I liked the way that that makes you feel.
And,
um,
and I really admire Toby and all of the York's pipe,
frankly,
because they do look ridiculous,
absolutely ridiculous and so much so that they just seem so other than they look
like aliens that you really,
I realized I never did talk to them because they did not seem human.
To be able to come in a room in Blue Bj's head to toe,
I mean you've got to see it
on your face and then pretend to be fearsome,
um,
is like amazing.
I'm sitting,
he overcame that outfit and became fierce and that's why it went talk to him.
It's pretty hard to take.
Clancy Brown is fear some though when he's on our board,
he's on a rocking horse and he's supposed to be a huge terrifying orc.
The Kurgan from Highlander,
you know,
this is a guy who should be filling it with fair and he's in his self phone,
pajamas
behind the scenes.
I've heard this story.
I do have to say one thing I very much appreciated about this film is that
wasn't like a Damsel in distress story and all the women in it are very bad ass.
Uh,
so thanks for that.
I'd love to talk about,
so you do have so much room to play with CG and cinematography and stuff like
that,
but I felt like there were a lot of shots that you wouldn't expect to see in a
roaring fantasy epic.
Um,
can you talk about sort of the process of working with the cinematographers and,
um,
I worked with Simon Dugan.
I'm on this film who had just come off of great Gatsby,
so he'd kind of been involved in something that involved a lot of special
effects work and postproduction and,
and building a film in Lez,
which funnily enough,
we were trying not to do as much as possible.
We,
uh,
Gavin bouquet was our production designer and he built these extraordinary
beautiful film sets.
So it was wherever possible even we were doing motion capture,
we would have these live action film sets to,
to shoot him.
Um,
but you know,
their work,
there were times when we were building things in layers and,
and,
and Simon and I kind of broke it down as much as we could.
But the nice thing about having as many live action sets as we had is we were
still able to be quite improvisational,
you know,
on the set.
Um,
I didn't have tons of storyboards.
I,
there were animatics but we didn't always stick to them.
A lot of the time we'd get on the set and we break things down and we'd work
out,
you know,
what,
there's a better way to do this.
And we do that on the day.
Um,
so it was kind of both unique and a little scary.
certainly scary for the producers because we were kind of working certain things
out on the day.
That's so true.
That was what it really was amazing that way people have been asking me what it
was like and was it really technical?
I guess it was like forget that bit because the sets were incredible and I
didn't feel locked down.
Like you can't move.
And I had a real person to look at and have feel their soul and I don't know.
Right.
It didn't,
you did it,
but more than I have ever done it.
But yeah,
that's what made it such an organic experience.
I feel like that transcends on screen too.
Just that human element.
Don't you think that
gun by saying earlier there was like the everyday it was just everyday was the
same,
but that's what I meant.
It's,
it was so inclusive.
It was like doing a full performance.
The fact that we now get to stand in front of Paula or Travis or Kim,
you know,
whoever we're doing the scene with,
I mean me and Paula,
we had to learn the ok-ish dialogue with a very specific more specific than if
you were doing say a year ago
p and accident like no,
no it's
not.
I would really love to hear the difference.
The actual,
I just,
that wasn't Jibberish I just said,
did you just like a fan somebodies mother or clearly,
but yeah,
so I mean it was absolutely like doing any [inaudible] doing a great film.
It was just on a massive scale.
So you kept,
I kept turning up and going,
did we,
did we do that?
How did we,
did we finish that day?
Language stuff you guys did was,
it was really impressive.
It really was.
There's a scene in hunt for Red October and I don't know if you've seen that
film,
you've youngsters,
but there's a,
there's a scene from a hunt for Red October where,
uh,
I think it's a Sam Neil who's talking Russian.
Um,
we're into submarines,
right to start the movie.
He's talking in Russian.
I know as the camera kind of moves in and closes in on him,
he starts speaking English and it's just really clever trans transition from one
language to the language that the audience understands.
Um,
and,
and you know,
getting rid of the subtitles but still allowing you to feel like,
oh yeah,
this is happening with this group of people who don't speak English.
Um,
and we,
we kind of used that guy again and elaborated on it a little bit for a meeting
between Durotan and the humans.
And Corona was doing the translation.
So you both had a big challenge.
You had a massive challenge cause you were speaking to different fake languages
and and starting in one and then having to transition to the other halfway
through a camera shot where we,
we're Toby speaking in org and then as the camera moves in he starts speaking in
English.
Um,
so the,
the special effects stuff was difficult but actually kind of stuff
that's really tricky to try and get the timing right to make sure that the
language sounds right and then an end to get the time,
you know,
to just do it all in all at the same time.
I remember being just,
I think that moment,
you know,
this was a long movie to make it and I remember we'd been waiting on this and he
goes,
no,
I want you to learn.
Arkish I was like,
wait,
what?
And the other bit too where it's Jibberish and then wait,
you ADR,
anybody does what I'm doing with these tusks in your mouth as well.
So you have a meeting at the same time.
And I just remember just being okay,
just fear sweat.
Um,
what Dunkin for you.
So your first full moon is one of my favorites of all time.
And,
and it's a very sort of,
um,
somebody saw it.
Yeah.
It's,
it's very self contained in a sense like set and scale wise and the actors wise.
And then source code is sort of a step up from that.
And then you just went completely all and what's next?
Uh,
little little film called little smaller film,
more like source code sized.
Um,
I'm going to do a film that I've been my don Quixote,
which is this Scifi film called Mute.
Um,
that's based in Berlin and I'm doing it with Paul Rudd and Alexander Skarsgard.
and a couple of other very cool people who haven't been announced yet,
but we'll be shooting that towards the end of the year.
Um,
I'd love to know for all you,
there's such a huge fan base for this,
like what's been one of the best fan interactions that you've had
so far from
this fruit?
From this,
but yes,
uh,
from you,
you should talk about music
from a film that hasn't been done yet.
Yeah,
no,
fair enough.
Cause I just,
cause I had a very strange occurrence.
I was in Shreveport,
Louisiana and a guy came up and his girlfriend brought him over and was like Joe
and show him and he pulled down his pants
and on his cheek and top thigh,
he had Johnny quit as rock and roller with the guns.
And he was like,
you know,
this guy was like,
well yeah,
I mean I played that guy and he would not believe it.
He just,
no,
I mean he was screaming and swearing off as mine.
Why did you show me that you're English?
I was like,
oh,
all right.
Yeah,
I mean for this and no one knows yet.
I think we're waiting
for that.
But yeah.
Yeah,
I know I don't,
I don't,
the fun is yet to come.
Let's see.
Cause see,
we'll be doing the conventions in like 40 years time.
The three of us will sit in there.
People coming up with a corona,
tattoos.
I mean,
you're a toy now.
You've
got to be a little surreal.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Chorus where you see things like that.
It's unreal.
Absolutely.
But haven't,
I mean,
I don't think anybody's put two and two together to have,
you know,
a fan
when the movie comes out,
whenever we can,
there'll be some Google searches going to fuck around with the test.
The fan fiction fan pictures.
And Colonel,
did I ever,
um,
everyone we have an audience,
Mike,
if anyone wants to ask a question,
if you guys want to line up in the middle,
um,
I,
this might be a tough question for you,
but you have a little one on the way.
Yeah.
Do you have a preference if they go alliance or hoard?
Uh,
do I have a preference?
Yeah.
Connie and I hope they go home.
You heard it here
Mayans,
because then they're much,
much better behaved.
Right?
But better behaved will be.
Yeah.
Elias.
Yes.
Hello.
Question is for Dunkin,
uh,
moon and source code where amazing.
Uh,
and then I saw a trailer for Warcraft and then I saw your name on it and then I
was like,
what happened?
Oh,
whoa,
whoa.
Let's say that that came out wrong.
What I mean is I didn't expect that I like,
and um,
and I didn't know what to think at first.
And then,
uh,
like yesterday or two days ago,
I read something on the Internet,
which I'm sure is a credible source for things that said that like,
um,
you were imposing all these different,
uh,
interesting new artistic visions on things like limiting the ILM guys to like,
not change the expressions of the CG characters with the mocap characters.
Um,
yeah.
Don't mess with Toby's MOCAP.
Yeah.
So rule number one.
So I'm interested just like what,
what did turn you onto making a big epic film based on a video game
and,
and then how have you,
what are some other ways that you've made it your own that's different from like
industry standards?
MMM,
gees.
Sorry,
not to jump on it,
but it's hard for him to sit,
but,
but as an act to watching,
you know,
what's incredible about a really good director of the high,
high level is they know when to say no,
not always about the yeses.
And you often see Dunkin a situation with people and it's like,
I hate to use this because it's so violent,
but if you're shooting a gun at someone,
nudges your elbow,
it may be a millimeter here but it's two feet off over there.
So he was very good about keeping a very steady aim constantly.
And that felt amazing for us as actors.
I think that's very important.
It's weird.
All of Toby's metaphors involves shooting guns,
love restraint,
that works for that too.
Mood,
mood in source code.
Obviously we'll sort of more like capsule pieces where you know,
once in a moon base once I'm trying.
Uh,
but,
but each one of them had individual challenges.
Obviously with moon we have one actor performing with himself and uh,
there's a technical puzzle that needs to be solved for that source code had a
different puzzle,
which was take a loop of story,
try and keep it interesting and different each time it's retold.
Um,
so I've always looked for,
I've always looked for difficult projects and,
and,
and with Warcraft,
I was a fan.
I've been,
I was truly a fan of all the Warcraft games right from the very beginning.
I love fantasy movies.
You know,
when I was growing up,
I love Scifi and fantasy and this was an opportunity to make a big fantasy film
and hopefully try and reach the same level that I felt like Peter Jackson's
original Lord of the rings trilogy had had basically set it for all fantasy,
but at the same time give it its own,
you know,
make it a little bit more room in the fantasy genre because I think fantasy is a
lot more constrained in what people are used to.
Then science fiction for instance,
which has loads of sub genres.
Yeah.
Um,
so yeah,
that's what we were trying to,
yeah.
I don't know anything about technical anything,
but I tell you that it's like nothing I've ever seen before because of that.
It's,
these visitors go on and on and I have a vantage point.
I keep talking,
I don't know how this is,
but I watched an imax and I watched it like an audience member and I was,
I'm real,
I don't know exactly what you did,
but you clearly did something different and new and clearly the way that you
feel about the CGI characters,
that not knowing that,
cause I was Kinda don't take this the wrong way.
Turned on by an org,
which I was like,
oh my God,
why do I think Dorian is hot?
Because heavy,
he like maybe
the Brad Pitt of books,
but the work he did
just sort of push them to the limit.
And I guess the nose too and all of it.
It makes it seem like something I've never seen before and uh,
it's magnificent really.
I have to say that
I'm super excited.
Oh good.
Without spoilers.
I will say there were moments that reminded me visually of like playing games.
Okay.
But not in a way that took me out of the film.
I was just like,
oh,
this would be like if I was playing like from,
you know,
it kept it a Flagstar one or the remote too.
I was like,
yeah,
this reminds me of like why that type of character would make that type of
attack.
It was super nerdy
before you noise if you're going to make a,
if we can make a film based on a game,
don't try and give people the same experiences playing the game,
but but still as a,
as a fan and a player of those games where where there were moments for the
camera to do things or to set things up in a way that are reminiscent of the
experience.
We tried to do it in a,
in a way that doesn't draw people who don't know the game out of the film,
but you know they're the,
it is full of Easter eggs.
It is a,
yeah.
There's a lot of Easter eggs in it.
Some of you think that we're approaching the end of days in our own world have
different political thanks for that.
Yeah,
go ahead.
I'm really curious how much you might've included concepts from current world
events in a,
and you're thinking about about that,
about this world?
It's
strange.
We've,
we've had a lot of,
um,
we've been doing a lot of press lately and,
and obviously we do domestic press and then you do international press and
talking to the journalists on the international press.
A lot of them,
especially the Europeans have asking.
So how has the immigration situation in Europe and in Germany and France played
into what you've done with Warcraft?
Obviously we were making the film three and a half years ago,
so we had no idea what,
what,
what's the situation in Europe is going to be.
But you know,
people will obviously pick up and read into things that are happening in the
real world.
Certainly our story follows very universal themes about the idea of one group of
people losing their home and having to find a new home in a place where other
people already exist.
So,
you know,
there's that,
but it's no more than that.
And that existed in,
in Warcraft Lore for 20 years.
That's the very premise of that universe is that these two very,
very different races have had,
I've been fighting because they can't find a way to coexist.
Thank you.
Hello.
I'm a huge fan of moon and source code and I was wondering how you found working
with an existing Ip,
both in terms of expectations from the licensed holders and the fans versus
making your own things.
There's a certain responsibility,
um,
to try and incorporate as much as of the,
of the trunk of the idea of what Warcraft is and the lore and the characters as
possible.
At the same time,
I want Paula and I want Toby and I want everyone else involved to be able to
create their characters because they're not going to feel real and less,
you know,
Toby knows why he's doing what he's doing and believes it and feels it.
And the same for Paula,
why she feels like she doesn't fit in this society or that society.
Um,
so you're,
you're constantly playing a,
uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm the chief chief diplomat of the movie.
My job is to make sure that blizzard feel heard and that we are creating
something which feels true to what they,
you know,
to a,
to a legacy that they have 20 years worth of storytelling.
And then also deliver a film that the studios and the producers feel like an
audience beyond just the fan base is going to enjoy.
And at the same time,
letting my,
my cast feel like they can additively put their themselves and what they feel
about their characters into the movie.
So you know,
you do,
you do end up doing a lot of diplomatic work and,
and hopefully,
you know,
you get to put a little bit of your own stuff in there at the same time.
So two questions.
One,
because we were here at Google,
I wanted to know if there's any thoughts of doing a source code to with,
you know,
more actual source code in it,
but more seriously,
uh,
this one's got a lot of CG obviously and a lot of world construction,
as you know,
film professionals.
Do you guys see more of this virtual reality entertainment intersecting with
what you will be to do over the course of your remaining careers?
Well,
you've just a couple of been her,
which is,
yeah.
Which is all live action.
All live action.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
We're pulling for real horses,
that whole thing.
Um,
I would like rather though to speak on our motion capture because it's a funny
time right now.
You know,
it's a very few select group of people who understand that what you do motivates
that incredibly beautifully drawn,
created character.
So it's basically a skin that is lifeless,
that has the dots.
Preston speaking on the,
on the code.
So the information that we give,
it's,
it's not a,
it's not a path that's going to lead you to great fame,
but it's,
it's going to be vitally important for telling these stories because even now I
watched a nice guys last night and they pan over the freeway,
come to him sitting in a car,
they're all computer generated cars and that just saves a vast amount of money.
So you can tell a good story without having to get 86 cars from.
And that in turn can put people out of business.
But you know,
things need to be rendered and captured.
And I think there's,
there needs to be some conversations about ownership of movement.
I had a conversation with Jeff White at Ilm about could you have,
not that you'd want to,
unless you wanted Ryan Gosling to play Toby Kebbell and a movie,
could you have his scanned and then have another actor play that body in a
movie?
Have we reached the point where the,
the fidelity is so good that an actual physical person,
you know,
it could be played by someone else and they didn't have an answer,
which was kind of interesting to me that no one,
I mean,
I guess the,
I guess the reason no one's done it because the obvious choices you hire Toby
Kebbell but I don't want to hire Toby Kebbell Ryan goes does,
but I want Ryan Gosling to play as Toby Kebbell in a movie.
How can you know?
Can I do that?
Uh,
I don't know.
We may never know.
Very good.
Might have just given them an idea is about,
you might have done,
why don't we,
we've got at least one Oscar winning effects person here in the audience.
So
cool.
Uh,
so Warcraft is a world with like a lot of lore and backstory.
Like you could probably make dozens of movies across like the whole series a,
was it difficult to try to explain it without spending too long?
Just like setting up why everyone's here and why they're doing what they're
doing.
Okay.
I think working with blizzard,
we were able to agree early on that there was no way we were going to be able to
tell the this big gap that Begat,
that Begat,
that begat that story,
which is what you know,
you end up with.
And Warcraft because they've been making these games for 20 years.
So we went to what seemed the most sensible point,
which is the,
the first contact story between ORCS and humans.
Um,
and then we chose a very,
very thin slice of that story.
So this is literally,
the ORCS are about to go through the doc portal.
So there were about to leave their home world.
We understand why they have to leave their home world and they're invading this
new world.
And I think by choosing that very thin slices,
we're able to fill that slice up with all of the detail that it needs to in
order to feel real and to not feel like you're being shortchanged.
It also actually happens to work very nicely for an audience who may know
nothing about Warcraft because it's simple enough and I think we're,
it's a,
it's a situation that an audience beyond Warcraft can understand
and at the same time have a great deal of friends and I'm like,
just be patient.
Hopefully there'll be more successful.
Your bit you love will come along,
you know what I mean?
So,
yeah.
Thank you.
We'll take our last audience question.
That's one of our question about the motion capture and it's sort of the
interaction.
Do you guys,
do you have some thoughts on whether it's harder to play opposite emotion
capture person or to be the motion capture person playing without actually
having hold up props and things?
Uh,
we're,
we're quite enjoyed working with you.
Thank you.
I enjoyed it.
She said very,
very dedicated,
very fee.
I mean,
by the way,
their worst.
She did have strings on her back when she leapt on that hot,
but I saw them slack.
I'm certain I saw them haven't very dedicated,
very hardworking.
I,
I just had that I've caught at the right point.
So from planet of the apes,
we would do a version with the humans.
I mean aversion,
36 versions of let's say 36 takes with the humans so that everything was
technically right and they got everything.
And then we'll do a clean slate,
which is where the humans who were in the scene or just the sets that are in the
scene,
I shop clean so the plate can have everything added later on.
Okay.
But,
but it's easy,
easy if you,
cause you get to look,
pull a pattern.
You'll cause she has to look.
John and yourself a pajamas.
Tyler,
I'm Catholic and English
was it
anyways,
sorry.
So that's the thing is that um,
I don't know,
to me it's all a game of make believe.
That's what I love about acting,
so I can easily in my mind,
ah,
go past the blue pajamas in the blue and the dots and,
and it didn't affect the performance for me.
I mean,
I just,
I was Toby,
he was giving me this character.
He was connecting to me through his eyes,
through soul and,
and vice versa.
And so it worked.
I mean,
I was so thankful because honestly I didn't know what I was getting myself into.
I've never done a movie like this.
I didn't know if it was going to be a tennis ball and a big blue room.
I didn't know how it was going to go down.
And then I was so,
so happily surprised that it wasn't that.
Yeah.
I think that just like life,
right?
You think you don't like certain people you,
but you get past any of it by looking through and you see their heart and their
soul and nothing about the exterior mount.
Okay.
I think it really helped that the producers really worked,
you know,
helped us out in that they kind of structured things so that by the time were
ready for those scenes where Paula and our other human cast,
we're going to be interacting with our motion capture costs.
We had started to receive work from Ilm that actually showed proof of concept
that this was actually going to work and it looked like this and it was amazing.
And the and and the,
the faces looked real than they look like the performances that are actors were
giving.
So I think you always have help it,
you haven't burned out,
but you always had a life size statue.
Yeah,
the oryx.
So that was always on set to remember for scale and mass.
We had that on onset.
So you always know that that was way before.
And so that's the thing,
that's the adjustment is we are now allowed to interact with the actors.
Whereas before we would have to go into a volume with the cameras and just do
the performance and watch a tape of them,
you know.
So now we get to do the live thing.
It gives it a real performance.
It gives it more genuine feeling.
Yeah.
So I think my very last question is,
uh,
so the game world of Warcraft,
I feel like changed people's lives.
Like people got married,
like met and got married off of this game in the real world.
Yeah.
I think people hold it in a dear place in their hearts.
And so what's one thing that you hope people take away from the film?
The trash.
And we're done.
All right.
Thank you so much.
And now
look,
I think one of the things that was great about the game
of Warcraft,
both the,
the old one in the world of Warcraft was the heroes can,
you can,
you can play as the euro on all sides.
And,
and I love,
I just like,
I liked that idea that,
that you can be the hero.
You know,
no matter where you come from,
most unexpected people,
the most unexpected places,
um,
that,
that's where the heroes can be.
And I know that sounds a little,
you know,
I dunno,
I like optimistic wishful thinking.
I like that.
Yeah.
Hi.
I get to romantic.
Well,
thank you all.
Some would,
oh,
sorry.
Did you?
Nope.
All right.
I'm going.
Um,
yeah,
so thank you all so much for joining us.
And we'll see.
Warcraft is it,
he does have one question about search and where the people would know what he's
been searching.
Yeah.
Nobody answered.
Nobody answer this one.
Big boobs.com
I like big boots.
I'm so sorry that that's what I felt.
It felt like a trap,
but when I saw you all here,
I realize that you're all on my team.
Oh,
good.
Great.
Thank you so much for joining us.